l'un des films événements de la rentrée
cinématographique c'est celui de robert
redford qui raconte l'histoire d'un
homme qui murmurait à l'oreille des
chevaux ce long métrage lyrique est basé
sur des méthodes qui existent
nous enverrons un exemple dans un
instant en france met tout de suite un
résumé proposée par pascal deschamps
pour tom hooper le cheval pilgrim est un
cas cruellement blessés traumatisés à la
suite d'un accident il ne supporte plus
le contact avec l'être humain qu'il rend
responsable de ses souffrances
c'est ainsi que commence entre le
guérisseur et l'animal une émouvante
relation une relation inspiré par des
personnages réels les chuchoteurs
l'auteur du livre a pris l'un d'entre
eux pour modèle son nom john brennan
c'est un cow boy il vit au milieu des
chevaux et les connaît bien
mais il passe le plus clair de son temps
à animer des stages pour apprendre aux
gens à se comporter différemment avec
leurs chiens plus débattre ou les
attachés à ne plus en faire des esclaves
c'est un mode de communication
particulier entre l'homme et le cheval
du subtil
ils ont tous deux un rôle le cheval sur
l'homme et le leader mais ça ne rend pas
l'homme meilleur que le cheval pour août
mais le film c'est aussi la
confrontation entre deux familles deux
modes de vie que tout sépare les cowboys
d'un côté la famille new yorkaise de
l'autre ça va vous en sortez un nom il
ya tellement longtemps que je n'ai pas
fait la cuisine j'ai compris et un
nouveau rôle en or pour kristin scott
thomas l'actrice du patient anglais
choisi phare est fort de lui même c'est
chaud je peux vous aider à vous pouvez
vous lutterez je suis à l'aise quand je
me souviens de la première fois quand je
suis arrivé à los angeles pour le
rencontrer je me suis trouvé comme tout
mais dînette
complètement idiote avec les genoux qui
tremblaient comme ça en train de luz et
souvent taj est en fait il m'a sauvé par
l'habitude il a navigué d'avoir des
femmes complètement gaga devant lui donc
il a un peu remonté comme ça et puis de
le retrouver comme metteure en scène ça
tu es formidable moi j'ai toujours aimé
ce film c'était surtout le mettre en
scène qui m'intéressait
et robert redford signe une oeuvre
pudique et grandiose où il parvient
comme chaque fois qu'il met en scène a
délivré un message sur les relations de
l'homme avec la nature
voilà alors